bonsoir bienvenue merci d'être au rendez
vous des grandes questions votre apéro
philo
chaque samedi à 19 heures ce soir
eh bien nous allons parler de l'histoire
après 60 ans d'une relative accalmie est
ce que l'histoire est en train de
redevenir tragique et bien c'est à cette
question que nous allons essayer de
répondre avec françois bayrou maire de
pau et puis futur candidat près
semblable à l'élection présidentielle de
son genre de panneau est un peu usé pour
que je tombe de novembre d'accord bon on
passe à la pierre conesa alors vous vous
êtes un spécialiste de stratégie
militaire vous publiez notamment la
fabrication de l'ennemi aux éditions
robert laffont et puis jean sévilla
notre anti historiens parce que c'est
l'historien anti politiquement correct
qui publie bas c'est une sorte de best
seller ça fait des années que ça dure
l'histoire passionnée de la france est
aux éditions perrin face à deux trois
invités no3 agrégé de philo eliette
abécassis gerling muhlmann et mazarine
pingeot et bien entendu vous pouvez
réagir tout au long de cette émission
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment avec
hashtag lg cul pour les grandes
questions elle raconte tout de suite
l'envié du sujet on y va vous voyez vous
une troisième guerre mondiale
quelque chose se profiler comme ça vous
êtes inquiet vous d'abord vous avez dit
quelque chose vous avez dit dans votre
présentation après 60 ans de relative
accalmie de relative accalmie pour nous
en europe parce que ailleurs dans le
monde
l'accalmie a pas été aussi sensible que
vous le dis qu'il ya eu de grands
affrontements de grande guerre
deuxièmement c'est vrai que vous savez
il ya eu un grand débat philosophique ou
d'histoire des idées parce que au moment
où le mur de berlin est tombé ya
beaucoup de gens
enfin il ya un très grand publiciste
américain qui a écrit que c'était la fin
de l'histoire pour tous que sa diversité
grand francis fukuyama
oui mais j'ai employé le mot publiciste
aussant sénégal y parle des affaires
publiques voilà le sens traditionnel du
mot et il a dit c'est la fin de
l'histoire est en réalité
évidemment beaucoup de gens en europe
ont crû que d'une certaine manière un
terme était arrivé mais moi je crois que
l'histoire ne s'achève jamais et que les
raisons qui ont fait les grandes crises
historiques elles reviennent
j'ai comme vous savez publié plusieurs
livres sur les guerres de religion mais
sur henri iv et sur la fin des guerres
de religion
aigri par vous même c'est assez rare
merci de le rappeler mais pour la clope
je vous verrez à la fin et donc on
retrouve aujourd'hui les ressorts
puissant qui paraissent très difficile à
maîtriser des grands affrontements qui
tourne autour de la religion plus
exactement autour de la volonté
d'imposer sa religion aux autres la
caractéristique des guerres mondiales
quand même c'est que les deux dernières
celles qui ont ensanglanté quand même
c'est affreux xxème siècle quand même
qu'il y avait autre chose à voir que ces
50 dernières années enfin ça a été quand
même des normes charniers et c'est
beaucoup demander derrière on les voit
pas arriver c'est secondaire
arrivées de trois ans avant mais on les
voit pas j'espère que non mais ce qui
s'est passé dans les années 30 était
avant coureurs on ne savait pas de quoi
et on n'imaginait pas que là que la
folie elle est là n é modéré idéologique
pouvait aller aussi loin l'histoire nous
surprend mais je vous assure que les
guerres de religion dont je parlais à
l'instant c'était pas tendre non plus
des analogies peu trop facile d'abord
les guerres aucune ne ressemble à une
autre un faudrait rappeler que en dans
les années 30 on attendait une guerre
sur un modèle de 14,8 et puis cette
autre chose s'est passé on attend la
précédent de donc si jamais il ya un
troisième conflit mondial qui se veut se
profiler ne ressemblera pas aux
précédents donc il vous par la pensée et
la préparer éventuellement selon les
modèles antérieurs
c'est le grand défi parce que par
définition il faut s'affronter du
nouveau le penser de nouveau et donc à
nouveau frais moi ce qui m'a beaucoup
frappé c'est qu'après les attentats tout
à coup le terme de guerre est réapparu
dans le débat public
en dix ans la france est en guerre etc
non il ya un abus de langage qui est
terrible parce que la guerre c'est quand
même la version des valeurs c'est
l'inversion des valeurs parce qu'il faut
tuer si vous tuez pas vous êtes tués par
vos congénères ce qui est quand même
inquiétant donc il faut quand même pas
trop utiliser ce terme
surtout quand on n'est pas en guerre
parce que la lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est pas une guerre on a eu un
président américain qui nous a expliqué
que c'était une guerre
on a payé cher cette erreur stratégique
donc on n'est pas dans cette situation
les palais de george w bush par exemple
oui effectivement il l'a déclaré la
guerre à la prolifération de terroristes
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
qu'on fait la guerre à des concepts
quand même c'était une création
intellectuelles originales et en fait
vous avez vu la suite il n'y a pas de
globalité il ya des crises il ya des
situations particulières et donc on
n'est pas en guerre enfin bon alors on
va maintenant s'intéressait plus
particulièrement à vous françois bayrou
au tour de l'europe ce que l'europe
n'est pas en train de devenir un champ
de ruines
non l'europe est en train de devenir un
champ de ruines ya une situation inédite
qui est à nos portes
une guerre alors absolument traditionnel
classique en ukraine classique
horriblement classique en ukraine qui
risque de difficulté économique de
vladimir poutine qui a intérêt à bouger
parce que ça n'a pas très bien dans son
pays bien sûr
bon et puis de l'autre côté il ya la
guerre que nous a déclaré à la france
bat c alors alors alors je sais pas si
le terme de guerre au sens si c'est un
terme plutôt métaphorique ou plutôt réel
mais la vérité oui c'est que nous sommes
cible d'un affrontement est partie
prenante d'un conflit avec le on va dire
oui l'état islamique le fanatisme qui
est décidé à imposer sa vision de la
religion par la force tous les
territoires qu'on domine rare mais c'est
en effet ça donne lieu à des scènes de
barbarie inouïe où sans précédent depuis
déjà quelques décennies
j'ai laissé maintenant entre les mains
de mazarine par jour mais alors moi je
voudrais vous poser une question sur
l'europe justement et sur l'identité
chez l'identité européenne
alors effectivement peut-être que si on
avait une défense commune voire un
ennemi comment ça pourrait renforcer
quelque chose qui serait de l'ordre de
l'identité l'europe s'est construite sur
des ruines à coups de volontarisme et
d'une
très belle très forte qu'il a raison
franck et le rationalisme plus jeunes
sortent le plus jamais ça et à la fois
des valeurs communes
alors c'est difficile de construire
quelque chose sur uniquement sur des
valeurs communes je voudrais juste vous
citer les propos de lucerne dans sa
conférence de 1935 à vienne qui commence
comme ça et qui ensuite se termine de la
façon suivante nous posons la question
comment se caractérise la figure
spirituelle de l'europe
et là effectivement il entend la raison
critique qui est né au vème siècle avant
jésus-christ avec socrate platon etc
et il termine sa conférence en écrivant
la crise de l'existence européenne ne
peut avoir que deux issues ou bien le
déclin de l'europe devenue étrangère à
son propre sens rationnel de la vie
la chute dans la haine spirituelle et la
barbarie ou bien la renaissance de
l'europe à partir de l'esprit de la
philosophie
grâce à un héroïsme de la raison qui
surmonte définitivement le naturalisme
le plus grand danger pour l'europe et la
lassitude
alors deux questions d'abord comment
essayer de créer une identité qui soit
supranationale alors des replis
identitaires qu'on peut penser une
identité précisément qui ne soit pas un
repli et deuxième question que fait-on
avec la lassitude vous posez la question
de l'identité européenne
pourquoi vous posez la question parce
que c'est intéressant de se demander
pourquoi cette question revient tout le
temps
est-ce qu'on peut bâtir une identité
européenne permettez-moi de risquer une
autre réponse
cette question elle est si difficile
pour les gens et si lourde et si
porteuse de conflits pour une raison
qu'on ne formule pas c'est qu'on croit
chez nous en france spécialement on
croit qu'on ne peut avoir qu'une seule
identité que si on est français on peut
pas être autre chose alors vous avez des
débats éternel sur la nationalité ou sur
le régionalisme comment de
le lit des régionales le basque le béarn
est le breton l'alsacien comment
peuvent-ils être français et si on
dépassait cette idée avec cette
affirmation qui est en tout cas la
mienne qu'on peut avoir plusieurs
identités en même temps et qu'en effet
il existe une identité européenne qui
nous distingue par le genre de vie par
là par la manière dont on se comporte
pas la manière dont on pense par les
libertés qu'on condamne qui forment un
ensemble européen par notre passé et par
notre manière de vivre
la question qui se pose c'est quand même
fou l'identité elle se définit par les
frontières traditionnellement frontière
et non la notion de frontières peut-être
soupe mais il ya une identité je sais
bien point est s no noise et du la
taille un point où quelque chose et
ensuite quelque chose n'est plus la
question de l'identité de l'europe est
aussi liée à ses limites si on va dire
où ses frontières pas ou censure
étatique mais où s'arrête l'europe
donc là on retrouve quand même identité
parce qu'on est dans le processus
d'élargissement européen est extrêmement
intéressant mais on élargit en est là
c'est juste un point ou un but mais tous
rencontre d'autres pays d'autres
frontières d'autres cultures et je veux
dire jusqu'à quel point ce syncrétisme
intègre-t-il ou non à l'europe donc la
question elle a coïncidé question n'est
pas neutre parce que voilà jusqu'à quel
point c'est la question était juste un
peu politique mais enfin légitimement
sur la question de la turquie parce que
la turquie est européenne ou non c'est
un débat enfin ce que si la turquie avec
les européennes on serait là aujourd'hui
avec des autres questions posées vous
avez posé une question
vous connaissez les tests carl schmitt
et on se définit par rapport à l'autre
et dire leur fonction des politiques et
définir l'ennemi
la caractéristique de l'europe c'est que
justement elle n'a pas d'ennemi c'est à
dire que on voit bien que le concept
stratégique entre 6 et 10 scandinave
ceux des français ceux des britanniques
ou ceux éventuellement chez ces peuples
au delà de l'autriche sont des concepts
stratégiques totalement différent une
moitié de l'europe a suivi georges bush
en irak dans une galerie de légal une
moitié de l'europe aujourd'hui il estime
qu'elle sa sécurité ne se joue pas en
irak et donc on a d'une entité qui
aujourd'hui en tout cas
pensé comme une totalité a déclaré la
guerre à l'occident donc à l'europe donc
ces matrices le ciel occident dans la
tête de dèche
s'il passait les lumières quand même là
on est sur un passé aussi frustré que
dix coups de vous prêter beaucoup de
gueule d'intelligence philosophico des
chiens je suis pas sûr que ce soit
obligatoirement l'idée même des lumières
ce qui est très intéressant si vous
voulez dans le comportement d'animosité
au d'hostilité de dèche c'est que vous
avez une espèce de hiérarchie qui
paradoxalement n'est pas celle que nous
imaginons les principaux ennemis de
neige sont les chiites
c'est à dire que c'est d'abord une
guerre de religion et c'est bien pour ça
que notre posture à nous est très en
porte à faux
avons nous à nous mêler d'une guerre de
religion il ya neuf états de la région
dans lesquels aujourd'hui je suis ni
theshit ce massacre est ce notre
fonction à nous de chevalier blanc
d'arriver au milieu le dire on va vous
séparer sauf que la gare maintenant
aller chez nous maintenant nous savons
est importée chez nous cette guerre de
religion est devenue la nôtre puisque
nous avons déjà chez nous non et nous
avons des religieux chez nous qui font
la guerre aux lumières c'est à dire à la
raison à l'humour enfin tout ce qui fait
cet esprit paul terrien l'irrévérence ce
qui fait l'identité de l'europe ans je
crois qu'on confonde de choses il ya le
fait qu'effectivement vous avez une
radicalisation dans la communauté
musulmane française moi j'ai sorti un
rapport justement sur quelle politique
de contreras localisation en france et
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que ce
rapport est sorti en décembre à une
époque où n'a eu aucun écho médiatique
malheureusement ou heureusement pour moi
il ya les attentats tout à coup c'est
devenu une question d'actualité
formidable et aujourd'hui vous voyez que
tout le monde ne parle plus que de la
radicalisation dans l'islam comme à ce
qu'on peut lutter contre dounia bouzar
etc etc et donc vous avez une question à
un moment c'est à dire que quelle est
l'image que vous vous projetez de
l'autre c'est à dire à quel moment est
ce que vous considérez que c'est l'autre
qui vous agressent voyez pas question
plus bon et cette question là c'est à
dire qu'il faut se poser d'abord en tant
que français on se demande pourquoi ce
processus de radicalisation et puis
deuxième question c'est de se dire est
ce que notre politique extérieure ne
contribue pas créé cette radicalisation
parmi les difficultés que l'europe a
flouté ya aussi des problèmes
économiques je pense à la crise
financière
avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec la
victoire de syriza qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
françois bayrou regardez attendre vous
savez il ya un mouvement assez générale
qui pense qu'au fond syriza peut obtenir
gain de cause et moi je pense que syriza
n'a pas de chance de succès ou bien le
probable est qu'ils vont décevoir
terriblement les promesses ou bien ils
vont se trouver devant un mur parce que
il n'est ce pas le sait des choses de
bon sens
ils ont promis je ne sais combien 12
milliards de distribution au peuple grec
il se trouve qu'ils n'ont pas le premier
euro et qui sont obligés d'emprunter
tous les jours comme nous aussi pour
faire les fins de mois comme on dit pour
payer les fonctionnaires par exemple ont
dit qu'ils n'ont pas de quoi payer les
fonctionnaires au mois de mars
et donc si vous avez besoin de cet
argent vous devez l'emprunter et quand
vous allez voir la personne ou l'entité
où la banque où les banquiers ou les
états qui peuvent vous prêtez c'est pas
une très bonne entrée en matière que de
dire je voudrais vous emprunter de
l'argent mais je vous rembourserai pas
le français qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
penser par rapport à ça parce que les
grecs lors doivent déjà beaucoup d'art
40 milliards way au peuple français sont
conseillers nous qui allons payer
d'autres non mais c'était la dette de
l'irak de saddam hussein ça qu'on annule
et vous savez oui très bien mais mais il
se trouve que vous pouvez enfin on avis
le le le le fait que nous puissions
emprunter à des taux extrêmement bas
vient d'une seule chose en tout cas
vient donner les manques principal y en
a 2 secondaire c'est que les prêteurs
pense qu'ils vont être remboursés et
s'ils pensent qu'ils vont être
remboursés alors ils prêtent à des taux
actuellement les plus bas de l'histoire
connaît jamais rencontré ce qui nous
fait beaucoup de bien comme chacun sait
ça va très bien et qu'on a mis dans
cette situation
mais bien je sais que beaucoup de gens
pensaient oui c'est certainement cette
raison que j'appelle la rupture
je pense qu'elle est une possibilité
sinon une probabilité parce qu'au bout
du chemin on ce que vous dites c'est que
la grèce risque de sortir de l'euro
quelles sont les conséquences pour les
français si si si la grèce quitte l'euro
comme vous le prévoyait alors si la
grèce quitte l'euro et prétend continuer
à emprunter
ça veut dire ne rembourse pas sa dette
alors nous aurons perdu 40 milliards
c'est-à-dire la moitié de notre déficit
annuel
on aura augmenté de 50% notre déficit
c'est quand même rude de penser que de
le choix de solidarité que j'ai soutenu
qui consiste à dire on va pas laisser
tomber un pays européens se
retourneraient pas ce que ça donnerait
raison aux européens qui comme les
allemands par exemple disait à l'époque
bassam est que la grèce centrale
donnerait raison de la grande crise
ça te fait plaisir à tous les gens qui
plaide le chacun pour soi
eliette abécassis pas ma vision
vous qui avez travaillé sur les guerres
de religion est ce que vous pensez que
nous sommes dans une guerre de religion
c'est à dire des gens qui pensent que
dieu existe qu'ils sont prêts à
sacrifier leur vie pour dieu contre des
gens qui ont dit dieu est mort et qui
ont coupé la tête des rois pas du tout
c'est c'est pas du tout ça les guerres
de religion ce sont des gens qui pensent
également que dieu existe qui pensent
également mais simplement qu'il ne lui
vois pas un croyant
lagardere des gens ça peut aussi être la
guerre complètement dans les guerres de
religion que
reste historique g20 historiquement en
france la guerre de religion du 16e
siècle
c'est une guerre civile à ses fonctions
car c'est au nom de la france la de la
religion c'est au nom de alors nous ne
sommes pas dans cette guerre là mais
nous sommes exposés à adé à des
mouvements terrible de gens qui eux ont
tu choisi d'imposer leur vision
religieuse à l'ensemble des terres
qu'ils contrôleront pour simplifier le
rsa c'est une message erronné ça n'est
pas chez nous alors l'année les
islamistes qui ont tué les humoristes
les policiers et les juifs qui font
leurs courses c'est cette année cette
année ce n était pas au nom de la
religion mais non on n'est pas en guerre
de religion il ya un abus de langage
terrible quand même vous rendez compte
de ce qu'on est et nos guerres de
religion par rapport à ce qu'on est en
train d'y vivre vous avez 5 à 7 millions
puis recommence à est ce que nos guerres
de religion qui était alors aux c'était
ça ne correspond pas du tout à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui mais ce cas n'ont pas
commencé comme ça mais non la guerre de
l'eau jusqu'à quand va commencer par moi
voilà la véritable guerre de religion je
passe aujourd'hui au moyen-orient c'est
à dire depuis las deux pilotes sur la
somalie jusqu'à jusqu'à liées au
cannabis et pakistan inclus c'est là bas
qu'elle se passe la guerre des religions
c'est pour ça que je pose la question de
notre rôle dans cette guerre là aucun
cas reçu en 2007
les vitesses mais l'épousé puis vient la
vente sont pas une guerre on a sept six
cinq à sept millions de musulmans alors
militaires qui sont en train de défendre
tous les sites
on a sorti l'armé l'a écouté il ya eu 12
séminaires organisés par des
associations musulmanes et ya encore six
en préparation qui sont toutes sur la
thématique la radicalisation que peut-on
faire contre c'est à dire vous avez une
classe moyenne musulmane française
musulmane qui s'est mobilisé contre la
radicalisation et ces gens là ne sont
pas en guerre contre la société x et
donc on n'est pas dans une guerre de
religion
dire qu'on est dans une guerre de
religion contre des savions qu il
s'entraînait extrémistes préciser les
choses il y as des as aux terroristes
des gens avec une vision une idéologie
une folie on en pourra employer le mot
qu'on veut en tout cas une barbarie qui
porte une horreur épouvantable qu'ils
ont choisi des cibles chez nous mais
nous ne sommes pas dans une guerre de
religion avec qui que ce soit nous la
misère contrat ni ministre essayons
difficilement de nous protéger contre
des assauts de cet ordre c'est protège
actuellement non pas deux catégories qui
n'ont pas de nom et qui n'ont pas de
religion ce sont des gens qui sont
décidés comme ça de l'espace et le
fondamentalisme islamique fils yamissi
qualifié vol qualifié fondamentalistes
islamistes ça ne veut rien dire c'est le
salafisme il faut le qualifier parce que
tout le reste des musulmans a besoin de
cette qualification
la majorité des musulmans qui
aujourd'hui pose aucun problème on peut
pas considérer accès l'état fondamental
vous voulez que j'assimile je n'ai pas
nommé n'existe pas non mais vous et que
j'assimile et ayant en effet un
mouvement qui date d'il ya 50 ou 60 ou
80 ans qui est un mouvement qui
voudraient ramener l'islam à un fantasme
et islam d origine de du 7e siècle
c'est ça que c'est ça l'essence à
l'invitation d'un mouvement politique et
il ya même deux de deux orientations à
l'intérieur ces gens là en effet nous
sommes en confrontation avec eux mais la
france n'a déclaré la femme n'étant
guère avec aucune religion et le fait de
vouloir à tout prix dire mais c'est si
si tout ça c'est c'est l'islam je ne le
crois pas je pense que l'immense
majorité madame l'immense majorité des
musulmans qui vivent en france
ils sont ils se sentent aussi
profondément blessé
d'autres et que nous le sommes et il se
sentant pas pu blesser l'ardeur et il se
sentait mentalement ce sont différents
il faut qualifier la cible pour ça qu'on
dit fondamentale ise de saddam et ans
mais voilà on utilise des concepts qui
sont complètement jean générique le
terrorisme international installé au
mali pour combattre le terrorisme
international s'il fallait combat
terrorisme international sera occupé de
l'irlande du pays basque ou des corses
quand on regarde les statistiques
d'europol ya eu plus d'attentats
régionaliste en europe comme d'attentats
islamistes
donc qualifiant la chose je sais que ça
pose beaucoup de problèmes diplomatiques
de qualifier le salafisme parce que
c'est l'arabie saoudite qui est derrière
mais enfin je reviens sur mon idée de
départ faute il défend de l'arabie
saoudite s'ailleurs docteur frankenstein
contre le monstre qu'il a créé bon alors
après avoir parlé de l'europe avec vous
françois bayrou on va aborder la
question de l'ennemi avec pierre
connaissent acquis qui a bien étudié le
vrai visage de l'ennemi à travers son
livre alors comment vous voyez les mille
et où c'est qui d'abord la réflexion a
commencé parce que j'étais seulement les
affaires stratégiques dans la décennie
90 c'est à dire le membre ou l'urss
voudrait fait la mauvaise blague de
disparaître et en fait quand vous êtes
dans les affaires stratégiques et qu'il
ya plus d'ennemis vous avez deux choix
soit c'est le chômage technique et la
baisse des budgets
soit vous inventez des ennemis c'est ce
qu'ont fait les américains à la décennie
90 1 c'est le clash des civilisations
c'est la fin de l'histoire et on prenait
tout ça mais alors avec une espèce de
fascination extraordinaire
rappelez-vous le chèque le clash des
civilisations été traduit en 35 langues
ça voulait dire que tout le débat
stratégique mondial était structurée
autour de ça il y avait des aberrations
le livre est très bien il y avait des
aberrations extraordinaire dedans mais
ont structuré le débat
bon il se trouve qu'après il ya eu le 11
septembre donc heureusement on a
retrouvé un peu de raison avec une
analyse stratégique encore plus
extraordinaire qui était celle de george
bush où il y avait 15 saoudiens sur 19
terroristes dans les attentats du 11
septembre et fait un discours en janvier
2002 pour expirer un axe du mal c'est
l'iran l'irak et la corée du nord
cette espèce de tour de passe-passe
stratégie m'a fasciné parce que je me
suis dit mais finalement le choix de
l'ennemi n'est pas une donnée sera
objectif c'est une donnée politique et
donc c'est là dessus que j'ai construit
la typologie des ennemis qui essayent de
couvrir encore une fois les 400 qui sont
les ennemis sous le pied
définir les uns parlent mais moi je suis
alors attendez moi je fais une
généalogie des ennemis ce maillot nous
on n'a pas d'amis on n'a pas d'ennemi la
demie à cette caractéristique de tout à
coup vous inversez votre système de
valeur c'est à dire je vais lui faire la
guerre parce que je ne peux plus discuté
avec lui et je vais lui faire la guerre
c'est à dire je vais m'autoriser à tuer
je veux obliger les citoyens tués quand
on est un état démocratique si on veut
faire la guerre il faut convaincre
l'opinion publique
c'est la caractéristique qui nous
différencie les dictatures et donc c'est
ce processus de conviction pour nous
amener à la guerre que j'ai essayé de
démonter et encore une fois si on
utilise le terme d' ennemi pour dieye
faut déclencher une guerre je pense nous
n'avons pas l'ennemi nous avons
probablement des postures dans lesquels
nous pouvons débattre le cas avec la
russie me paraît plus caricature on a
nous même créé une situation de conflit
sur la crimée donc je veux dire un peu
c'est un peu toujours notre foot quoi
c'est toujours la faute de quoi qu'il
arrive
non il d'une certaine limite c'est
l'américain non mais attendez j'ai pas
dis que c'est la mairie je constate
simplement que c'est le quatrième
président américain qui décide et
l'invention une invasion militaire en
irak donc le jeu donc quand même
quelques doutes au bout du compte c'est
pas l'irak a envahi des états unis
encore une fois donc le fait de se poser
en tant que démocratie les processus de
conviction qui nous amène à la guerre on
va parler un travail de philosophe je
renvoie la travailler nos
interlocutrices mais ça me paraît un
travail essentiel première fois et en
déclencher des guerres en se disant
regardez le processus de l'attentât
terroriste
là on a eu l'égorgement quatre
occidentaux on a décidé d'aller envoyé
les troupes et évidemment avec un
discours sur le thème ça ne se passera
pas comme ça on sera mangé
moi j'étais né en algérie en 54 quand
les époux monroe ont été égorgés et on a
eu le même discours ça se passera pas
comme ça il faut envoyer la troupe
on a envoyé le troc vous connaissez la
fin de l'histoire est donc encore une
fois ce processus qui médiatiquement
tout à coup fait déraper le langage en
disant nous sommes en guerre
on va réagir militairement et ce
processus contre lesquels le politique
devrait avoir un minimum de rationalité
en disant lutte contre le terrorisme
avec des moyens des avions spéciaux avec
des services action avec du
renseignement avec de la police mais on
ne dote pas avec des moyens militaires
genre c'est déjà pour savoir qui est
l'ennemi faudrait aussi se rappeler de
l'histoire jeudi 11 mars et provoqué
aussi des ennemis parfois qu on
appauvrit
or artificiellement parce que par oubli
de l'histoire dans le cas de la crimée
et bouble ukraine
bon je pense que l'europe est
extrêmement prudente en oubliant
l'occident si ce mot un sens en oubliant
que l'ukraine est historiquement un pays
frontières au dès lors qu'on a voulu
cela toujours été un pays à deux ponts
entre l'est et l'ouest dès lors que
l'ouest pour faire court cerveau
d'autrefois
enfin bon a voulu s'annexer on veut dire
l'ukraine jeudi rationnaires culturels
économiques et bien forcément ça allait
déclencher une réaction à l'histoire
l'oubli de l'histoire c'est la même
chose au proche et au moyen orient on a
voulu déstabiliser l'irak je la liberté
renoue bien que ce sont des pays jeune
aussi et en projetant des réalités
l'allier on ne sait pas trop ce que
c'est en fait proche des réalités
étatique qui sont des concepts
occidentaux sur des pays qui ont des
systèmes parfois tribaux avec des
divisions religieuses extrêmement forte
que vous avez évoquées mais tout ça
c'est de l'oubli ou de la méconnaissance
soit il est à côté à apprentis sorciers
en fait dans l'attitude de l'occident
c'est ça on s'est pas rendu compte que
certains états de tenez que comme des
bâtiments en ruine parce qu'ils avaient
des étais tout autour pour c'était la
guerre froide si vous voulez donc il
fallait surtout pas toucher parce que si
nous on s'en occupe et c'était le havre
qui risquait de venir et tout à coup il
ya des états qui sont décomposées la
somalie en est un exemple aujourd'hui
plus personne ne se préoccupe de ce qui
se passe en somalie alors que rappelez
vous il ya encore une quinzaine d'années
il fallait absolument faire une
opération militaro-humanitaire ces
nouveaux comme concept l'intervention
militaire n'a jamais a permis de
reconstituer un acteur bon alors dire
que déjà je vous met maintenant entre
les mains de jradou ce sera plus alors
vous dites qu'on ne doit pas se mêler de
conflits entre religions là où nous
n'avons nous ne sommes pas naturellement
bon alors c'est d'accord on peut
philosopher mais c'est bien se mettre à
la place des politiques imaginons que
vous soyez françois hollande et vous
recevez un coup de téléphone du
président malien qui vous dit il ya des
forces islamistes dont al-qaïda et qui
occupe déjà toute la partie nord de
montpellier
jusqu'à tombouctou et par la terreur et
il ya un film qui s'appelle timbuktu qui
vont très très bien comment ça marche
comment ils s'installent et ils sont en
train de descendre ils seront à mopti
dans 48 heures c'est à dire au sud du
mali
aidez nous ils sont tout près de bamako
la capitale malienne jérôme absolument
48e le savoir ce que j'aurais fait oui
le mali était classé 110e dans la
hiérarchie de transparancy international
si les touareg sont en insurrection
depuis 20 ans c'est parce que les aides
vont leur a promis qu'un suivi les
grandes sécheresses nord sont jamais
arrivés c'est à dire qu'on est en train
de défendre un régime auquel encore une
fois on n'a imposé aucune
conditionnalité politique mais ce que je
veux dire l'intervention militaire on va
faire intervention militaire pour
arrêter la progression des islamistes
deuxième remarque vous avez remarqué
qu'ils ont détruit les bibliothèques
tenus par des mâles et quitte donc on
revient dans une problématique qui est
interne à l'islam c'est à dire que ce
sont encore une fois des salafistes qui
avait fait exactement le même type de
comportement
quand abdel wahab avec l'insee au don
prend le prix la mecque
ils ont détruit le biotech ils ont même
voulu détruire le cimetière dans lequel
étaient enterrés les compagnons du
prophète ils ont failli détruire la
tombe du prophète
c'est pour vous dire si en terme de la
peut-être que les khmers rouges s'ils
voulaient dans la même catégorie
et donc cette catégorie là si vous
voulez c'est un problème qui aujourd'hui
concerne l'islam
ce sont les mâles équipes qui sont en
train de se mobiliser contre ce qui se
font se sont allégées et donc pour les
fans c'est pas une guerre de religion
qui nous concerne a fait perdre
localement pour arrêter une progression
militaire c'est une chose mais si on ne
pose pas de problématique politique on
revient dans la situation de
l'afghanistan ou de la libye voyons vous
a rendu service maintenant débrouillez
vous non c'est pas possible donc vous
auriez exemple j'aurais imposer des
conditionnalités politiques comme
d'ailleurs à l'intervention militaire en
quelle est la nationalité politique
notre international processus électoral
il ya eu des déserts ou présent mais
enfin je veux dire on peut bien dire que
les moyens de la politique extérieure
extérieur que personne n'a jamais pas en
contre c'est le fait que la corruption
est une donnée stratégique aujourd'hui
si des états se décompose en particulier
en afrique dans laquelle on annule
d'ailleurs très souvent la date avait
remarqué en particulier au congo zaïre
qui était effectivement l état le plus
riche de free donc si on adule la carte
milliards comme ce serait pour la grèce
certes mais en fait avec mauboussin vous
déteignait quand même de 12 milliards de
choses notamment donc on est dans des
situations aussi on ne prend pas en
compte la conditionnalité politique
d'une intervention militaire
on fait ce qu'on fait partout on envoie
du militaire puis ensuite on le retire
ça nous coûte cher
j'ai fait le calcul de ce que va nous
coûter l'afghanistan et attendez vous
parlez pas y aller parce que mali tout
le bolide plein de gens trouvent que ça
a été la seule guerre légitime est
relativement bien à l'arrêt ce vraiment
la réponse de françois bayrou
non moi je pense que l'opération mali
était indispensable et qu'elle a été
bien fait
alors sauf quand les temps aujourd'hui à
toutes et tous le savent et c'est vrai
que c'est très bien fait mais je pense
moi qu'elle a atteint son but est que
c'est moins désordonnée que ça n'a été
fait ailleurs je pense que l'armée est
intervenue de même d'ailleurs ça valait
bien sûr par exemple la mer
non je pense que là on a rempli une
mission d'urgence car imaginer que la
chute d'un état aurait donné à un foyer
politique central et des moyens
étatiques aux forces que nous
définissions avant et qui sont rentables
moi en tout cas j'ai soutenu
l'intervention au mali j'étais opposé à
ce qu'on aille je me suis opposé à ce
qu'on aille bombardé la syrie parce que
je trouvais que c'était absolument pas
dû la même chose et pourtant tout le
monde beaucoup de mes amis et de mes
concurrents étaient du même avis il
fallait aller frapper la syrie
moi c'était pas mon avis mais j'ai
soutenu une intervention malige ne va
pas de l'avoir fait je crois que je me
suis mal exprimé
j'ai toujours dit qu'une cour une
intervention militaire devait être
conditionnée par une analyse politique
de la situation et une conditionnalité
politique c'est exactement la situation
en irak aujourd'hui on va défendre leurs
habits s'adonner saoudite qui a donné
naissance au salafisme qui aujourd'hui
le monstre qui se trouve dans l'état
islamique
mazarine pingeot j'entends enfin sur
l'airé est question géopolitique etc ces
chiffres qui tablent sur les sunnites
enfin est plutôt inverse d'ailleurs mais
les populations civiles dans ça on l
attendait il ya deux choses différentes
le fait qu'on déforme des minorités
chrétiennes qui sont persécutés par
l'état ni de fait pour défendre les
yazidis est une chose mais c'est autre
chose que de faire un bombardement
c'est autre chose est ce que vous pensez
qu'une bombe de 250 kilos de 500 kg com
la question s'était posée à gaza est une
manière de le faire de la lutte
antiterroriste non non et justement à
propos de la guerre entité enfin la
lutte ont tiré de tori c'est quand on
parlait de guerre tout à l'heure c'est
intéressant
cette terminologie de la guerre
effectivement je pense comme vous qu'il
s'agit pas d'une guerre qui fait la
tension avec les mots mais néanmoins on
est quand même face à des nouvelles
modalités à savoir vraiment entre
guillemets une file guerre pardon je
vois pas d'autres mots pour l'instant
asymétrique c'est-à-dire quoi on est
face à un ennemi invisible et c'est
peut-être ça qui crée cet espace de jeu
pas d'atmosphère d'angoise anxiogène et
d'impuissance parce que ce qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
il ya un aspect aussi que vous avez
soulevé c'est le fait que c'est une
guerre sans front c'est à dire qu'il ya
une partie civile partis là bas et c'est
la première fois qu'on est face à cette
situation où le phénomène de radical
c'est une guerre non bah oui c'est le
jeu m'entendre iliad et free
c'est la première fois qu'on a une forme
de radicalisation religieuse dans
lesquelles le phénomène d'écho
international est aussi fort quand on a
eu jim jones quand on a eu lors du
temple solaire quand on a les témoins de
jéhovah on n'est pas sur un phénomène
sectaire il est religieux aussi mais qui
n'a pas cette résonance si vous voulez
aux questions nationales non mais
justement c'est ça qui caractérise la
suite c'est une étape de même nature et
à ce qu'il change probablement par
rapport aux 11 septembre c'est que
l'organisation même s'est transformée et
al-qaïda s'ils voulaient en deux mots
pour comprendre ce qu'était al qaïda il
fallait lire aujourd'hui pour comprendre
que l'état islamique il suffit de
regarder c'est à dire c'est un
changement fondamental de méthodes de
propagande qui est donc on est dans
quelque chose qui est qui explique que
nos jeunes si vous voulez tout à coup ce
sens pour billy's et sur cette espèce de
tiers-mondisme nouvelle génération
eliette abécassis
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train de se
voiler les yeux et de dire arrière les
canons au moment d'un comme ce qui s'est
passé comment hitler a annexé l'autriche
et puis qui massacrent et l'egypte
là il ya des massacres de chrétiens des
massacres massifs
il ya des vrais front de guerre dont il
est ce qu'on n'est pas en train de se
retirer du jour disant non non non mais
ça nous concerne mais ça va bien se
passer les grilles en 3g
ces massacres j'ai dit défendre des
minorités défendez yazidi défendre les
chrétiens d'orient dès lors les défendre
comment ah bah écoutez ça il ya des
méthodes qui sont autre chose que de
bombarder le fait qu'on fasse des
opérations militaires de dégage enfin un
moment donné on est obligé de faire la
guerre si on veut défendre des chrétiens
qui sont en train d'être massacrés
massivement et abandonné je vois bien
non il ya d'autres méthodes
il ya d'autres méthodes ses confrères
mais quelles sont ses méthodes combat on
peut faire des zones sanctuarisées comme
on l'a fait on a besoin de sécuriser ça
veut dire des zones militarisées dans
avec l'ennemi c'est donc à une
intervention là on sait que vous voulez
il ya une zone frontière ont construit
une frontière artificielle c'est autre
chose que de faire du survol aérien de
bombarder et ensuite se retrouver avec
des populations qui finalement se
solidarise avec la avec la cible c'est
exactement la population de l'allemagne
pendant les grands bombardements les
allemands se solidarise avec hitler
parce qu'ils trouvaient injuste d'être
bombardé de manière indifférenciée dans
ses villas de remarque une de fond
d'abord pour donner en partie raison il
ya ta bécassine tout ce qui est vrai
c'est que tout en faisant toutes les
distinctions ne sait évidemment on est
d'accord distinguer l'islam du
terrorisme
tout est d'accord là dessus c'est
évident enfin la zone d'extension du
terrorisme se trouve dans le pays où
l'islam est présent
donc ça donne un terreau possible je ne
fais pas les assimilations donc jeudi
l'extension est aussi liée qui crée ce
climat d'inquiétude c'est qu'on ne sait
pas d'où ça peut partir dans quel pays
où il y a de l'islam ça peut démarrer
cette radicalisation ne précise pas
leurs objectifs leur vie entre
l'affrontement au sein de nos pays entre
les musulmans et le reste de la
population de manière que un fonds
secret et que en masse les musulmans
rejoignent la déstabilisation
l'autre élément important et c'est sur
ce point qu'on regarde l'histoire c'est
que la france traditionnellement est
toujours été un grand pays militaire
depuis 15 20 ans il ya une sorte de
consensus social culturel autour de
l'idée qu'il fallait réduire le budget
de la défense que la chose militaire
n'est pas si importante dire or on
s'aperçoit brusquement d'ailleurs
président
landes vient soudain coup de prendre des
décisions enfin ces rencontres on
s'aperçoit que si l'armée on a le besoin
et qu'on aura de plus en plus besoin
je pense que c'est un choc culturel dont
on n'a pas besoin de voir que il ya
quelque chose qui fait sourire c'est de
voir que combien les forces de l'ordre
ont été applaudis au mois de janvier
y compris par tous les soixante huitards
qui criait daguerre csss ça ça fait
sourire voilà mais aussi sourire si la
chose était dramatique voilà je vais on
est en train de la gagner but à sion qui
est forte dans notre histoire politique
c'est dire qu'on va redécouvrir
l'importance d'un fort sens du facteur
militaire de jus dans la gestion à
l'année temps mais je voulais le fait de
décider tout de suite dans l'émoi des
attentats d'augmenter les budgets et les
effectifs des services de renseignements
des services de police c'est une
réaction normale
je pose une question de savoir si
l'armée a un rôle à jouer en matière de
lutte antiterroriste
c'est la théorie qu'avait développé
george bush avec l'invasion en irak
rires on l'a fait en afghanistan à
chaque fois ça a été un échec donc
utiliser le utiliser des attentats sur
la question budgétaire dans le chocolat
ensuite ensuite la diana c'est comme si
tout ça ne fait pas une politique
je pense qu'il faut radicaliser moi je
pense qu'il est assez spécial raffarin
outil de défense
oui mais un outil stratégique parce
qu'on ne sait pas ce qui peut arriver et
que si on avait à parier c'est parce que
vous expliquez que ce budget défend sa
carrière j'ai passé vingt ans mais ça va
si on avait comparé à une armée ça sert
à faire un certain type de conflit eh
bien je dis simplement que si on avait à
parier le pari le plus raisonnable c'est
de penser que nous allons nous retrouver
devant des situations inédites et pour
ça il faut avoir une capacité de réponse
avant d'aborder avec vous j'enseigne la
lente historiens enfin l'historien anti
politiquement correct la question de la
france est ce que la france peut se
réconcilier avec son histoire
moi j'ai une petite question toute
simple opposé d'heure on voit bien qu'on
est tous un peu plus ou moins hanté par
l'idée du déclin la descente aux enfers
de la france elle a commencé quand vous
lancez historiens
jaguar ville disait en plaisantant que
déjà sous louis xiv ça allait mal donc
et pourtant ils étaient monarchiste donc
je crois pas ça toujours été mal donc
c'est pas c'est pas non je crois pas
voilà que ce soit 14 va toujours mal je
crois pas la notion de décadent déjà
sous clovis le débat le déclin avait
commencé
oui oui non non ça je crois pas je crois
pas ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas la
question pour un pays c'est savoir si la
maîtrise de son destin
si l'état est à la hauteur des défis
collectifs
quels sont les rapports avec son voisin
avec ses voisins ça c'est les vraies
questions à l'appui la question aussi
évidemment c'est la prise en compte ou
non de son identité le mot est un
parfait parce qu'on a des identités ça
je pense aussi mais enfin savoir qu'il
ya quand même un pays à un être
qui détermine une certaine forme de
culture de civilisation de forme
politique est ici on néglige tout cela
est bien on ampute la réalité et on est
aveugle en sera vous devez biche
énormément ce moment parce que le sous
titre par exemple de l'histoire
passionnée de la france qui semble
best-sellers comme ça continue ça
devrait être fier d'être français mais
en ce moment on sent bien qu'il ya une
grande partie des français qui sont
fiers et bien que même fait applaudir
j'aime c'est sûr je ris oui même s'ils
sont un peu tristes là vous êtes en
train de devenir politiquement correct
on a fallu casser les gens qui étaient
politiquement correct qui me rejoignent
tôt que moi je voudrais jouer
j'aimerais jouer non mais je pense qu'il
faut il faut être fier de son pays
les b s'il veut pas dire être aveugle
sur vous êtes parfois vous trouvez on a
été formidable partout en tout noir de
l'histoire
enfin je vais on peut pas écrire
l'histoire uniquement avec sa voix là et
en revanche c'est une histoire
formidable que celle de notre histoire
et qui est une histoire qui m a dit
peut-être rassemble c'est précisément je
l'espère sera en tournoi enfin autour
des débats qu'on a autour d'eux après
poste attentats enfin ce débat qui dure
depuis trente ans en réalité c'est que
si on se veut un destin collectif le
vivre ensemble vivre ensemble lui
ensemble dans un pays un pays la france
je suis désolé c'est une nation donc
c'est un fait d'histoire si on veut pas
dire qu'on aime l'eau n'est pas européen
on est aussi aimer la france je dire ça
peut concerner tout le monde quelques
choix d'où les gens viennent quelle que
soit leur couleur de peau la religion
mais enfin c'est être de la france il a
il a une histoire encore faut-il
apprendre le connaître les laits et se
mouler dans cette histoire est une
histoire un visuel ça c'était quelque
chose de singulières parce que nous
sommes un des seuls pays qui soit une
nation et que par exemple quand vous
dites aux espagnols à mes voisins
basques
catalans qu'ils sont une nation
considèrent que leur nation c'est pour
la plupart entre le pays basque et la
catalogne et que l'espagne est aussi
vous entendu nous être furax à nantes
sera engagée que ça vient non je pense
que en france la réalité que nous sommes
une nation que nous sommes ensemble avec
très forte adhésion
c'est une réalité originale en europe
si nous sommes une nation est ce que
c'est pas parce qu'elle la mer c'est à
dire tous ces peuples qui ont reflué un
moment ils se sont trouvés bloqués c'est
la grande thèse de jacques baril
c'est à dire et puis la lave à la france
a commencé à constituer à se constituer
parce que je pouvais pas aller plus loin
oui au sérieux je pense qu'elle est
surtout l'appel l'appel a le pouvoir de
l'état chilien nous sommes une nation
politique
nous sommes une nation parce qu'on a été
construit par l'état d'où l'importance
de la politique en france fuyant les ai
construit par l'état
d'abord les rois de france la république
napoléon de serrage dire le rôle et le
rapport que nous allons à l'état est lié
à notre histoire nous sommes une nation
politique c'est mal qu'à l'allemagne
sais c'est pas le cas de l'angleterre
qui a valu qu'elle soit c'est pas le cas
de l'italie fait pas le club sait pas
pas le cas des ailes nous sauvera une
seule des construite par les singuliers
et c'est bien comme ça et c'est très
bien alors ça nous empêche pas de vivre
avec les autres
c'est ce à quoi le commun que parce
qu'il ya ces intrusions implicite
puisque qu'il faut qu'on tranche il ya
des gens qui disent parce que nous
sommes singulier nous n'avons pas vivre
avec les autres ou le moins possible ou
d'un peu loin ou et d'autres qui pensent
que parce que nous sommes singulier
c'est intéressant que nous vivions avec
d'autre part en abandonnant notre
singularité au contraire mais parce que
nous avons quelque chose à dire oh non
seulement à dire mais à partager
avec d'autres et le fait que nous ayons
pu faire vivre ensemble des peuples
enfin des communautés régionales par
exemple différentes
c'est intéressant alors c'était lié à
tabac 4 6 qui va s'occuper de vous
maintenant j'en sais villa alors vous
critiquez l'histoire de france et enfin
l'enseignement l'histoire de france
politiquement correct parce qu'elle est
idéologique et c'est une idéologie cube
et culpabilisatrice selon vous mais il
semble que dans votre histoire de france
vous fassiez exactement ce que vous
reprochez aux autres évidemment avec une
alors journée beaucoup alors les rois de
france ils sont tous merveilleux même
sans lui casser des massacres qui ne
mettent pas à mon avis pas trop le nom
le monde sait comment 2015 je me
souviens tu allais son merveilleux alors
en revanche vous n'aimez pas du tout la
révolution française la commune c'est
une horreur
alors le pompon c'est pétain dont vous
dites qu'il voulait régénérer la france
vous ne mettez sans guillemets alors
pourquoi la france est elle dégénérés
est-ce que c'était à cause des juifs des
francs maçons des républicains si je
vous souhaite c'est très petit chat
comme attaque parce que c'est vraiment
ça correspond ni à ce que je pense qu'il
ya ce que j'ai exprimés 10 danses livni
ailleurs alors dans son jeu au prix
impasse parce que je veux dire j'ai fait
un livre d'histoire qui est un livre
d'histoire factuelle qui raconte
l'histoire s'est écrite ou factuelles
c'est seulement c'est vraiment ce n'est
pas pouvoir
du point de vue du royalisme fait pas du
tout mais alors au sens laura moye se
découvre une succession de portraits de
200 n'est pas du tout ça dépend des
révolutionnaires qui sont on a pas le
temps qu'on n'a pas le temps de
développer tout ça ici dans les trois
litres que nous avons pour en discuter
ce n'est pas vrai je sais ce sont des
fêtes je raconte l'histoire de france
qui c'est vrai que la monarchie
française à exister dans notre histoire
puis il ya une révolution qui a été un
événement majeur et populaire jeu on
aurait pu faire l'économie la rémission
français ça j'en suis persuadé a su
persuader
écoutez je veux dire il faut rétablir la
monarchie mais ces problèmes ne se
posent pas la question si elle était
rétablie ça ne me dérange pas mais je
veux dire les lisant les britanniques ou
l'hébreu ou les belges les espagnols ont
une monarchie je détaille dans son île
ce qui surprend pas plus loin sur soi
des démocraties qui se porte bien aussi
donc je dis ne faites pas des
assimilations trop facile de dire donc
le débat n'est pas là je veux dire si je
fais un livre d'histoire qui raconte
l'histoire de notre pays
ce n'est pas vrai que je m'inscris en
faux quand ans après votre affirmation
selon laquelle je ferai une espèce
devient en hausse de la france jeudi
non mais vous trouvez vous la trouvez
toujours formidable mais peut-être que
nous a un peu raison ça fait du bien
non mais c'est pas vrai sur pétain mais
je vais enfin j'en perdais faire
l'exégèse de mon lit mais je veux dire
si si si si parce qu'il ya des phrases
c'est quand même gênant quand on écrit
l'histoire de france c'est notre
capacité à donner des leçons à tout le
monde c'est à dire qu on explique qu'on
est le pays des droits de l'homme ont
aidé à gagner le titre définitivement
comme les brésiliens sont champions du
monde de football définitivement et on
explique à tout le monde
quand on signe en 48 la charte de l'onu
sur les droits de l'homme on est la
deuxième puissance coloniale de la
planète
c'est quand même fascinant c'est à dire
cette espèce dif ou de schizophrénie qui
est la nôtre pour expliquer que nous
sommes très très bien de côté et très
mauvais de notes ses autres
caractéristiques
c'est à dire qu'on est incapable de
tenir un discours de la cohérence fier
de la révolution je ne dis pas compris
la question à la limite c'est pas enfin
quel est votre positionnement politique
c'est que vous dénoncez effectivement
dans l'enseignement de l'histoire en
france on forme d'idéologie qui serait
la bien pensante qu'effectivement une
idéologie très médiocre qu'on va dire
mais comment faire l'économie d'une
forme de logique dès lors que l'histoire
sont sani selon un récit et retour et si
tout roman alors d'autant plus le roman
national est nécessairement biaisé par
une forme d'idéologie qui est celle du
présent on raconte toujours l'histoire
de notre présent et notre présent
évidemment n'est pas nettoyée de toutes
les idéologies par définition par
définition et sur historia sur le reflet
d'une époque
depuis notamment dans la pédagogie où
effectivement on a beaucoup met en avant
le récit parce que c'est plus pédagogue
la boîte à malice et quant au canton
tout est une partie des fêtes
je veux dire quand vous dites je dis du
mal de la mission française dont je juge
insiste mais je n'ai jérémy parution
française à ça mais je veux dire la
dimension terroriste de l'oeuvre
française était quelque chose de majeur
or je dis aujourd'hui on fait silence
sur cette partie là mais je veux dire ça
a été ça a été c'est la première
expérience globale du d'une dictature
par une minorité qui a exercé son
pouvoir de manière de manière tout à
fait terroristes dans un bureau la
terreur est pas un idéal politique pour
moi c'est que même à peu près le contre
exemple alors terrain je veux bien non
mais simplement pour eux l'idée commence
à l'être a fait ça fait 20 ans qu'on
commence en effet à dire la vérité mais
j'ai une âme il ya encore pas si
longtemps que ça
les grands universitaires louait la
terreur c'était c'était la position
officielle à l'université ont considéré
que c'était une de ces têtes c'était une
mesure nécessaire indispensable qui ont
été prises à terme il est possible c'est
comme bon marché
de l'avis de tous cas il est possible
que la révolution soit un bloc et que
rien de tout cela n'était en réalité
évitables vraiment c'est possible mais
en tout cas la terreur peut pas être
présentée comme un idéal ou quelque
chose
alou je voulais revenir en une phrase à
votre affirmation selon laquelle au fond
comme l'histoire enseignée est un récit
c'est une idéologie
moi je crois pas ça je pense qu'il ya
une approche laïque au sens ce
respectueuse des faits capable de
traduire ce que sont les horreurs d'un
côté les idéaux de l'autre et qu'on
n'est pas obligé d'essayer de soumettre
les élèves on a tous et j'espère ici on
n'est pas obligé de soumettre les élèves
à
à la domination d'une vision d'un regard
aujourd'hui je vois je crois tout en
veillant à ce que dans la sélection du
programme on est on est d'emblée est
nécessairement c'est pourquoi la
sélection chronologique n'est pas
absurde
en tout cas moi c'est quelque chose à
votre analyse
moi quand j'ai passé l'agrégation
d'histoire je croyais que j'avais
effectivement compris c'est à dire je
voyais bien effectivement comment le
passé les choses s'enchaînent et
rationnellement etc
ensuite j'ai participé pendant 20 ans
des décisions publiques je me suis rendu
compte comme en été prises les décisions
publiques et je me suis rendu compte du
travail de rationalité que fait
l'historien ensuite pour expliquer que
les acteurs sont rationnels qui ont
travaillé qu'ils connaissaient les
dossiers qu'ils réfléchissent et c'est
alors que pour aux décisions auxquelles
j'ai participé parfois les plus graves
je me rendais compte qu'il y avait un
amateurisme extraordinaire
extraordinaire un peu d'ail et donc ça
peut arriver et donc on est dans cette
situation là où le travail de
l'historien idéologiquement ces deux
supposés une rationalité des acteurs
alors alors trop long pour revenir au
tragique de l'histoire
on n'est pas dans une période qui
pourrait préparer une nouvelle
révolution c'est peu dire il avoue santé
ça parfois ce qui est tout à l'heure a
été a été dit je crois que c'est par
vous qui disiez il faut mettre de la
rationalité dans la politique dans la
démocratie et c'est ça au fond le moi je
pense que démocratie c'est plus souvent
des passions que de la raison jeu on
peut le on peut le regretter
on peut le regretter et c'est même pire
parce que très souvent on constate que
les acteurs ont fait le constat en tirer
la conclusion que ces faits plus souvent
des passions que de la raison est très
souvent ils pensent que les patients
voire de détestation de rennes
d'affrontements sont plus fortes que les
passions positif et je crois que c'est
vrai mais la vocation ou la noblesse en
tout cas ce que je m'imagine être la
vocation politique c'est précisément de
contredire cette fatalité là et de dire
que on peut être là aussi pour ne pas se
livrer à cette surenchère passionnel
même si elle est électoralement payante
c'est un débat que j'ai eu avec nicolas
cercle français qui disait dans le
tempérament français même le pack dans
le passé même le futur était meilleure
oui je veux dire c'est à dire
qu'effectivement on est dans un
processus intellectuel où le tragique
prend tout à coup une connotation qui a
parfois rien à voir avec la réalité
oui j'en vois moi je vois qui est du
tragique possible dans nos lycées en
cela que je me tapais extrêmement
divisée quoi il n'y a pas de noms je
voulais bien c'est le contraire il ya eu
le bougeant vielles mais est ce que ces
partis fille ciel la grande manif voilà
c'est il ya une grande fragilité notre
société parce que ya pas de valeur je
crois pas moi malheureusement qu'il vous
fasse décoller fragile vous le centriste
moi je trouve en tout cas que que ce qui
s'est passé après le 7 janvier a une
grande signification je ne dis pas que
cette signification soit déterminante
qu'elles soient à jamais mais la phrase
que j'ai trouvé pour le dire c'est la
france quand on la cherche
on la trouve et il ya eu là une offense
terrible contre ce que confusément nous
pensons que nous sommes et ça a provoqué
une réaction vous rendez compte quarante
mille personnes à pau cetc
proportionnellement plus qu'un million
et demi à paris n'est ce pas sorti
simplement parce qu'on a dit on va aller
dans la rue et on va et on va dire que
c'est impossible
il me semble que c'est quelque chose
d'important et de positif je ne sais pas
ce qu'on veut en faire il est trop tôt
pour le savoir
mais à la question au fond que vous avez
abordé ce qui est celle de l'unité du
pays l'unitarisme je dirais presque du
pays
il me semble que ces manifestations ont
apporté un début de réponse
les gens ne se sont pas divisés alors
que tout était fait pour ça
c'était même le but des attentats à mon
avis les gens se sont pas divisés ils se
sont réunis pour dire non c'est pas ça
et c'est pas chez nous et c'est pas
comme ça c'est parce que nous sommes est
aussi
difficile à apprécier que soient la
nature et l'avenir de ce mouvement pour
moi je le trouve positif alors peut-être
est ce mon idéalisme et on optimisme
voilà merci bien je rappelle les titres
de vos livres
un amoureux de la france qui raconte
l'histoire de la france l'histoire
passionnée de la france c'est aux
éditions perrin pierre conesa la
fabrication de l'ennemi c'est aux
éditions laffont et puis deux
exemplaires des oeuvres complètes et
abondante de françois bayrou de la
vérité en politique et la france
solidaire c'est écrit par l'auteur lui
même sans aide
voilà merci à la semaine prochaine même
jour même heure c'est à dire samedi à
19h pour une nouvelle édition des
grandes questions à son prochain